freedom of the press is only guaranteed
when you own the Press Communication
Breakdown pause for the message wake up
every station is a gentrification Global
syndication is the shaping of the nation
ABC Disney
murder against foxy and we're the hint
he owns a pen the camera the sword by a
Coke by Ford getting broke getting bored
and it curious yours from the earliest
days freedom of the press was what
defined America Thomas Jefferson helped
write the Declaration of Independence
believed a free media was essential for
a free Nation saying where it left to me
to decide whether we should have a
government without newspapers or
newspapers without a government I should
not hesitate a moment to prefer the
latter
that was in
1787. today our newspapers seemed to be
fading in importance in a multimedia
world that is largely owned and
controlled by a handful of large media
corporations I think we're probably the
most media dominated Society in the
world
Jeff Cohn worked in major media now he's
one of the industries fiercest critics
half a dozen corporations
own and control most of the mainstream
media in our country so if you're
looking at who rules America or who owns
America it's the same people that
propagandize to America the press and
the outlets that report news or convey
information are just a small slice of
vast media Empires producing
entertainment products that also sell a
way of life based on consumption
when you look at who's on the boards of
media corporations they're also on the
boards of U.S oil companies and they're
on the boards of U.S military
contractors so trying to study who owns
America you're really also these are the
people that own the media we don't have
a state media but in some ways it's very
much like a state media it's the
corporate state if this is true and we
can say that the American Media doesn't
just report news as we'll see it's not
independent of the system but a pillar
of it it reinforces the world view and
defends the interests of those who rule
America
30 years ago 50 companies dominated
American Media now it's down to six here
are some charts on media ownership that
illustrate this concentration
with new Global digital Enterprises like
Google Facebook and Twitter growing in
importance worldwide us-based media
became a transnational Force
so U.S media companies are themselves
owned in large part by hedge funds
mutual funds and finance companies Barry
James Dyke is an asset manager who has
studied media ownership the research
which I've done is is unequivocal and I
kind of stumbled into this is that the
the media companies the major media
companies I.E the Disney's The cbs's the
news corporations
all of them this is all public documents
is that they're all owned actually owned
by mutual fund companies the majority
shareholders are owned by mutual fund
companies so um and also they also get a
lot of their revenue from these
companies so you're never going to see
any consistent criticism about these fun
companies are these companies
investigated by the media no they're not
are they responsible to the public in
some way are they accountable to the
public really know what they're doing
the public really doesn't have a clue
they really don't know what they're
doing he has documented his findings
with charts in his own book The Pirates
of Manhattan
well then people are not going to begin
not getting the truth
but there is a lot of coverage
especially of politics that's often
treated as a sporting event with an
emphasis on poll numbers and election
results Mary Boyle follows media
coverage of Elections for common cause
what about the role of the media is the
media helping to strengthen our
democracy do you think it's helping to
divide us well I I think that's a great
question I I think that
um you know there are a couple of things
going on there obviously you've got kind
of cable channels that are
you know in different camps and they are
not showing different points of view
you've got Fox News showing the right
you've got MSNBC showing the left
um and so with a setup like that you you
have Americans that are just kind of
tuning in to the channel they want to
listen to that you know kind of
expresses their views and and you're not
seeing kind of a mix of an opinion a
debate anything like that you've also
got you know the shrinkage of of the
media you've got less coverage of of
what's going on and I think this is
particularly concerning uh more around
kind of state-based and and local
politics where there's even less
coverage of of what's going on in
politics
but even as the world is known for its
diversity American media is not
editorially and ideologically the power
elite tends to reflect the views of the
government and the people who shape its
views the sensing politicians like
Congressman Jesse Jackson Jr have a hard
time getting their views heard who owns
the media
how the media has translated some of the
Moguls and the titans of media and
Industry are part of the problem
they shape a narrative for the American
people a narrative that ultimately leads
millions of people to vote for
candidates based upon the narrative that
they shape based upon the talking heads
that they control and
those Americans tend to vote and tend to
engage the system on the basis of that
which they hear media is a significant
part of this problem
historian Eric foner agrees he says it's
not just political bias at work but what
the media as a business feels it's
forced to focus on to attract ratings
and revenues
somehow that idea of of power uh behind
the people in office is not really in
our media very much it's not really in
people's minds very much they
personalize politics their personalities
combating each other but they don't look
at who's behind the scene well you're
quite right that the media focuses on
personalities you know and and and often
the quirks of Personality Clinton's uh
sexual escapades or whether Obama was
born in the United States or not or
Romney and his uh cars and whatever you
know is not paying taxes and many other
things those are not totally unimportant
issues but maybe it's the nature of the
media today in and of itself in that it
it you know it has to go for the quick
news deep investigative reporting is not
emphasized as much as perhaps it was in
the past and um you know you got to sell
papers and Scandal sales papers
um personality sales pay celebrity sales
papers so uh you're right that the you
know the the larger nature of how the
system operates tends not to get
emphasized as much it's not even
understood by many people well it's hard
to understand this is a very large
country over 300 million people are very
very complicated economy and political
systems so it's it's difficult to
understand exactly how things operate
but I think
but but I think you know in a certain
sense the anti-government sentiment
which is Rife in this country which is
generally associated with the right wing
is also a response to the feeling
it's an encourage feeling it's not an
analytical feeling but it's a feeling
that government is aloof it is not
responsive it does not really represent
the people it represents some very
particular interests and that sense is
pretty widespread in this country
Media Watch groups are also concerned
about the lack of diversity within the
media that makes it unrepresentative of
the country it serves in racial ethnic
and gender terms
the unwritten Credo of the New York
Times is do not uh alienate those for
whom we depend uh on for money and
access Chris Hedges was an award-winning
journalist for the New York Times and
American Media star
and that means the power elite and the
financiers who advertise uh so uh but
but it's it's expandable I mean you have
you have at least in the positions that
I was in the possibility
uh to do journalism not that there
aren't you know restrictions or
constrictions there are
um and not that they can't be punishing
hedge's work is still very respected but
he believes that much of the press is
ultimately a charade that covers up for
power more than covers it especially
when reporting on elections
because the political theater I mean the
personal narrative of the candidate it's
all irrelevant it's meaningless uh and
and people we you know we still play the
game look every totalitarian country I
covered had elections they all play the
charade I mean even East Germany did uh
and uh and that's the charade we play
and when we have a compliant corporate
media that pretends that that charade is
real
um so I think uh the problem is that the
illusion Still Remains so powerful but
people are changing but the illusion is
still so powerful that people confuse
where power actually exists
how does the New York Times cover the
power centers that many people say rule
America Chris Spanos and it's the New
York Times examiner that monitors the
newspaper's content every day he
believes the paper has become an
accomplice to the power elite
the New York Times as an institution is
almost like a mini nation and in the
correspondence the the op-ed writers the
editors they're almost like diplomats
and how they they they carry themselves
and their own self-importance and in a
way that they communicate with other
politicians and diplomats and they are
very influential would you say that
they're a disseminator of ideology in
America not just of information
absolutely they're they're they
disseminate a very particular ideology
and that their readership is primarily
managers
um and and people who make around over
90 000 a year and and so they cater to a
managerial perspective and and so they
they have a Pro Management when they're
discussing labor relations they often
have a pro-management view a
pro-business view
Financial journalists like Stacy Herbert
and Max Kaiser found that many
pro-business views in some media Outlets
were often uninformed as they told me on
a radio show
from December 2008 so well after the
collapse of bear Stearns Lehman Brothers
the Marcus tumbling a thousand points in
a day and the head of BBC World News
business said
and we had a 10 episode contract do you
think the financial crisis will last all
the way through these 10 episodes
so in other words the people actually in
charge of planning the coverage are are
very uninformed themselves well the
mainstream media are themselves deeply
in debt you know the the news
organizations have become entertainified
and and to compete they take on enormous
amounts of debt so the bankers they
don't want to to to insult their
creditors because they might cut off
their lines of credit so they don't have
they're not unbiased in this Regard in
any stretch of the imagination you see
this most spectacularly with the New
York Times They their their coverage of
the Wall Street is pitiful
one reason the Press is so pro-business
is that they are themselves businesses
the people who run media companies
increasingly pay themselves huge
salaries and bonuses the same way that
Bankers do says Barry Dyke they're less
moonves I couldn't believe he made
59 million in 2009 and he racked up it
was just as close the other day that he
made close to 70 million in uh 2010 and
that's the head of CBS that's the head
of CBS but you're saying that all of
them are are really running their
businesses as if they were Banks I mean
that's pretty good that's Banker pay I
mean 70 million dollars a lot of money
in anyone's book and that's what they're
getting paid
so the the media companies are really
part of this whole system of who rules
America they're they're part of these
interconnecting interlocking
relationships with financial
institutions there's no question but
there's no question about you get the
the media companies which are huge it's
part of the Empire get the media
companies you get the bankers of course
you have the your massive you know uh
unions okay you have um
uh other uh factors as well but those
the media is definitely part of it and
the asset managers that's exactly it the
corporations that own the U.S media and
own U.S television are very wealthy and
very powerful and the people at the top
of the news networks get paid an awful
lot of money I have never earned
anything close to the amount of money I
earned in the one year I worked where
General Electric was my boss at MSNBC so
what I think happens is a
self-censorship where the people who
rise to the top have learned how not to
rock any boats
and they know if they do rock boats they
will lose their huge salaries
newspapers like the New York Times The
Washington Post and the Wall Street
Journal tend to frame a deeper narrative
that tells us what we should believe
matters
they set the agenda that influences what
TV news programs also cover for example
they don't focus on inequality and class
differences as Independent Media
executive Brian Drew lay
they don't talk about the working class
and part of it is it's like the the idea
that you know they promote this idea
that you know if you buy a lottery
ticket you could win right so you're
already thinking that maybe you could
win so if you're in the if you're in the
working class or you're part of the
working class that's unemployed you
still have this hope that somehow you're
going to go into the middle class
there's been very little attention paid
to class I mean you were saying that the
media really doesn't discuss this they
don't really highlight class differences
in America they're much more comfortable
talking about racial differences or
ethnic differences at the same time in
their business practices they're very
conscious of demographics what class are
they attracting upper class how to cater
their advertising how to sell it no they
go I mean you know the internet is a
perfect example that the only thing
where they're constantly slicing and
dicing who you are so they know exactly
how much you make so they can pitch what
kind of products to you but that's
that's this whole sort of Madness of the
consumer Society that's been created by
modern capitalism but the the key thing
I think that you're getting at is is
that even though there is a reality of
Class A working class in this country
and a ruling class or a Boudoir class
people have been trained not to think in
those terms so they don't even know who
they are
some networks like Fox News owned by
Rupert Murdoch seem to be more
comfortable presenting a right-wing
political line they have helped shift
many media Outlets to the right there is
a school of thought that says we should
have given the citizens of Baghdad 48
hours to get out of Dodge and flatten a
place then it would be already over and
we could have done that in two days that
may be so but old media is being
eclipsed by the new says George Scribner
the vice president of digitas a company
that comes up with digital strategies
for big companies and studies how
affluent consumers now Drive Marketing
in an era of growing economic inequality
the one thing that's different now is
that the media is owned by everyone
you know there's there the only the
thing that's kind of leveling off the
dollars to some extent is that everyone
has access to Twitter everyone has
access to blogging and there's this new
kind of fast and fluid Coalition
building like Occupy Wall Street what
street was one example of that uh the
Arab Spring wasn't an example of that so
in some ways kind of the the there's the
check there's a new check and balance I
don't think that's necessarily changing
the restructuring of income and wealth
but I do think there's another trip
switch that that might help us when
things get too bad so the digital media
in a way is where democracy exists today
it's not in politics it's not in big
business it's not in big money that's
true I think that's well said
there is some debate on how free the
internet really is given corporate
control and government censorship but it
does make possible more interactivity at
the same time media attention still
tends to revolve around the political
Elite with authority even if that elite
doesn't necessarily have the power to
shape priorities or impose policies
but when you talk to ordinary Americans
many of them feel it's totally fair
they're seeing different points of view
they're seeing people who are critical
from time to time they're you know they
see the media as the liberal media in
some instances I was in the Soviet Union
and it was we were always raised in this
country that that's pure propaganda and
frankly it was very ineffective
propaganda because they never pretended
to have two points of view they would
have some one point of view saying how
great things are but in our country
propaganda is really effective because
they have the appearance of debates the
United States of America will not permit
the world's most dangerous regimes to
threaten us Jeff Kuhn says that just as
Americans were misled about Iraq before
the war they are being misled today
about Iran he pointed to a study about
Iraq before the American Invasion that
found that of some 393 people who were
interviewed on all the networks only
three were anti-war because almost
everything we knew about Iraq before The
Invasion turned out to be false and
almost everything we're learning today
about Iran
is uh not accurate and we you know we
went to the New York Times a couple
months ago where they said that the
international atomic energy Association
has put out an assessment that the
nuclear program in Iran has a military
objective and the fair this media
criticism group went to the times and
said which report is that we've never
heard of it the times knew they'd made a
big error it was a prominent error They
removed the sentence from their website
but they refused to correct the error
it's not just Wars that get
propagandized media does not often cover
the people behind the scenes who run
things says William Hartung who has
written about the military-industrial
complex you would think there would be
some Independence
in the journalism on this issue but in
some cases reporters have even said to
me well you know I can't go after the
Pentagon harder or the company's harder
or this Nexus of influence harder
because uh this company is a big
Advertiser in the paper and we'll get
pressure you know if we do those kinds
of stories so we'll do stories about the
more in Afghanistan we'll repeat what
the president has to say on an issue but
there's not really a lot of interest or
resources put into investigating these
kinds of connections David Swanson who
also writes about military policy agrees
well the corporate media in the United
States is integrated with the
military-industrial complex some of the
same corporations are making profits
from both there are two major political
parties that don't have much
disagreement on this topic so it's not a
topic for debate no matter if 90 of the
public is upset about it it's not
acceptable news
Michael Claire who's investigated the
destructive power of oil and gas
companies says the same is true when it
comes to that industry the media doesn't
cover this for the most part in fact the
media is largely in League because of
the advertising dollars that the oil and
gas Lobby provides they're very heavily
dependent on Advertising Revenue so
they're very careful in what they say
big business a wealthy and frequent
Advertiser in the media is often not
scrutinized by the media that was the
case in the financial crisis as Sheila
krumholz of the center for responsive
politics so these are complicated issues
the issues are are difficult to
understand on a good day and they seem
again very Arcane and and unimportant to
the average American so it's possible
that that some media were
laboring away trying to explain why this
was critical information that the voters
need I think a lot of blame though can
be laid at the at the feet of the media
for the financial collapse ultimately
what we do know is that it's critical if
there if there's any uh perfect uh
scenario that shows why transparency and
paying attention and scrutinizing the
the powerful players and what they want
and what they're doing to get get their
way
the financial crisis is is that perfect
example it shows us how important
transparency is because significant
wealth demands
[Music]
significant together we can give you and
your wealth the wings to soar
Goldman Sachs Wealth Management
at the same time media has become so
pervasive online and off on TV and on
our mobile phones that many Americans
say they are becoming victims of
information overload the more they watch
the less they know
for sure information overload is I think
a a a serious threat to democracy
because it doesn't work if people aren't
Vigilant nobody's going to hold
members of Congress accountable for you
you have to take you have to make sure
that you're heard
I think there's also the the sense that
because there is this tension and some
would say healthy tension
between uh concern about protecting the
process democracy and government from
monies undue influence versus protecting
freedom of speech and privacy nobody
wants to censor information we want our
representatives to have all the
information even if it's coming from
Deep pocketed corporations unions or
trade associations very narrow interests
we just want to make sure that they are
doing their job to seek alternative
perspectives even if they're coming from
groups that have no power and have no
money
media criticism tends to revolve around
what's being covered and not covered and
not on the way media narratives shape
how we think and what we think about
that's the power of media and why it is
now among the forces ruling America
[Applause]
hello Chicago every school child learns
power in Washington is formally divided
three ways between the executive branch
in the white house now occupied by
Barack Obama in the judicial branch
topped by the Supreme Court with nine
judges all political appointees and the
legislative branch where the Senate has
a hundred members with two from every
state and the House of Representatives
435 drawn from districts across America
this is the formal system of checks and
balances that is supposed to keep the
country on the stable course of
democracy
and yet wherever you go in this capital
of America and meet the people who are
the most informed about how the
government really works you hear that
the system isn't working and that the
voters are not in charge
you hear it from a member of Congress
who controls America
uh an elite group of people who function
in a stratosphere
globally and Beyond the Constitution
beyond the reach of government they have
enormous resources
you hear it from an expert on our
elections our politics are being
hijacked they're being hijacked by
anyone by people who are willing to
spend millions of dollars to you know
elect or defeat certain candidates you
hear it from the head of a public
interest group we have a plutocracy we
have a corporate plutocracy and the
rules in Washington are written by the
corporate lobbyists working on behalf of
the biggest corporate interest in the
country and you hear about lobbyists
from a veteran former Congressional
staffer who would only talk to us of his
face and voice were altered
99 of the people that I see lobbying
Congress are white men and women who you
can tell are where very nice expensive
suit and ties and dresses and they are
going into the Republican offices
I rarely see African Americans here I
rarely see Hispanics I rarely see Asians
I rarely see Muslims
um it's like you see these very
well-dressed
guys who just came off Lear Jets
and you can tell they're right out of
the country club
and they're going to the Republican
offices asking for a tax cut of some
kind these are not just opinions this
well-researched book by William domhoff
details how the government today is
being run by powerful Elite forces
outside the government as we will see
his conclusions are supported by
experienced insiders here in Washington
DC all of these insiders say that money
and special interests are now in control
they too ask who rules America in
Washington we spoke with leaders of
three respected Watchdog organizations
that specialize in researching and
analyzing hidden forces operating behind
the scenes
public citizen focuses on corruption and
accountability issues Robert Weissman is
their president and described how laws
get passed
how does a piece of legislation emerge
how does it become law how does it get
implemented and how does it get enforced
at every step of the way you really have
sort of corporations in whatever
industry dominating the process why
don't congressmen the people we elect
challenge the system well they are
products of the system and so they've
got an inherent bias a favorite look
they've succeeded in the system one way
or another and those who challenge it
are going to have to fight really
entrenched power so of course there are
many of them who are very good and who
do challenge the system but by and large
people got to Washington because they
figured out how to make the system work
for them even if they came in as
insiders most of them were quickly
educated on the ways that things that
really do work in Washington if they
hope to get things done or get reelected
and they succumb to the corporate
interests where does the money come from
the top 100 donors have given 77 percent
of the money going to Super Pacs that
means one percent of the donors are give
giving 64 percent of the money this is a
tiny Elite that can afford to make the
contributions that are going to be most
influential in this election cycle
this website
opensecrets.org documents where all the
money in politics originate Sheila
krumholtz oversees it as the executive
director of the center for responsive
politics I think many of the people who
are concerned about money's role in in
Washington and how it greases the skids
for for uh
private narrow interests to kind of Rule
the Day believe that the money is the
the members of Congress and policy
makers control uh the levers of power
but that the donors the kind of patrons
of these people are operating the
strings the politicians are kind of the
visible locus of power but the but the
people behind them really are calling
the shots how do we find out who those
people are
well we have millions upon millions of
records of donations to Federal
candidates political action committees
including leadership packs which are
their kind of slush funds that they
control and the parties we also can see
money going directly to the super Pacs
these are the uh political action
committees which are supposedly are only
giving contributions uh to groups that
are spending money to run independent
expenditures independent of the
campaigns and parties the problem is of
course that there's this Secret
pot of cash being collected by groups
that do not disclose where the money's
coming from and they are running
advertising political ads which are
often quite damning and nasty and not
sometimes irresponsible but are highly
influential and we have no idea where
their money is coming from
she showed us what their data shows a
small minority controlling the process
with very few millionaires funding all
politics
there are 610 registered super Pacs 190
of 95 of them are ponying up the money
for the ad so far but this chart really
demonstrates what a dramatic increase
we've seen in spending on Advertising by
these groups so in 200 2012 we're seeing
over 100 million spent that's a hundred
percent increase over the amount spent
in 2008 and a 400 increase over last
cycle
this is a who's who of who's lobbying in
Washington between 1998 and 2012 the U.S
Chamber of Commerce spent
831 million dollars the American Medical
Association
269 Million Dollars General Electric
268 million dollars
the pharmaceutical research and
manufacturers of America admit to 219
million plus for lobbying and there are
many many more
2012 could be a turning point in
American politics because of all the big
money that's literally being invested
Mary Boyle is the vice president of
common cause
in who is ruling America you certainly
have to look at the people who are
giving the most money to political
campaigns they are highly influential
people who give a lot of money to
political campaigns millions of dollars
you know want something for return they
tend to be really Savvy business people
who have made a lot of money because uh
you know they know what they do they're
doing and they don't make investments
without wanting an investment on their
return
it's unfortunate but obviously it buys
media time
um it also buys a constant uh male
efforts and also obviously you support
uh candidates who will ultimately come
to the United States Congress who may
vote your way
the largest contributors to political
campaigns in America are the financial
institutions uh the second largest
contributors are large real estate
developers that means that if you're
running for office you have to get
elected by premising to support policies
that are supported by the real estate
sector and by the uh financial sector
that lends to the real estate sector
and doesn't this really kind of put the
Democracy under threat yeah I mean
corporations are free now due to
Citizens United and a couple of other
court rulings to give more money than
they have ever been allowed to be before
and that is certainly a threat to our
democracy because what it does is it
drowns out the voices of Regular People
it's uh you know discouraging in one
sense and that you know the election of
2008 showed a tremendous number of
people who want change and yet there
seems to be at every turn change is
being resisted by minorities that are
very skillful at undermining change
certainly 2008 was the you know change
election and we have been disappointed
there there has not been more change
coming from the White House at WWE now
that President Obama is running for
reelection he too is spending most of
his time raising money two billion
dollars for political campaigns that's
why Robert Weissman says this Scandal
involves both parties
yeah it's a bipartisan problem for sure
the uh the 2 billion is just the
presidential race the over the overall
national race will probably be around 8
billion Obama is an extremely talented
fundraiser so he's going to be able to
raise big money the massive chunks of
outside Super Rich money and corporate
money though look like they're going to
go overwhelmingly on to the Republicans
it is so expensive to run for office
whether it's a presidency or the state
legislature that you just have to go out
and start raising money from people who
want something in return to run for
office
the money in politics just doesn't
Finance candidates it pays for lobbying
in 2011 there were 12
654 lobbyists spending 3.32 billion
dollars on influencing politicians
agencies and regulators
I was with a group of 20 women from the
Middle East last week and we said they
wanted to know about code pink in our
work and I said come to Congress and
meet us and we met in the cafeteria and
we looked all around said all these
people are lobbying Congress and they
think they're going to have some
influence but the influence doesn't
happen here there's a special place in
the capital that special people go to
that we can't go to and that's where the
people who have money go to do the
lobbying and they also have their
special parties where they pay a lot of
money to have a face to face with their
Congress person that's where things get
done the scholar Francis Fox Piven says
that's because of another problem not
all Americans can or do vote
very twisted and very distorted system
of electoral representation uh it is
distorted not only by Big Money although
that's certainly very very important
because of the advertising and the
campaigning that it makes Possible A lot
of people do not in fact have the
franchise and even
vote are not represented fairly people
in uh smaller states have more
representation and so forth so this
helps explain why small but well-funded
groups like The pro-israel Lobby or
pro-military Lobby can have so much
impact Joanne Landy has examined who
makes foreign policy it's an informal
network
of the people who rule America even
though they don't go around wearing
signs saying We Rule America that's who
makes the pilot whether it's with
politicians or whether it's with think
tanks or with the military or you know I
mean it's they're all interconnected
Landy says these lobbies are more united
than divided another disagreements among
them but there are disagreements about
methods not goals you know so
of some nuclear weapons other people
think you should hold on to them all but
the differences are really they cover
the gamut from A to B as they used to
say the sort of day by day
run-of-the-mill reality is that those
who have uh High positions in politics
and strong connections with moneyed
interests and the moneyed interests
themselves run the country
we are now on the way to the Congress
which now enjoys less than a 10 approval
rating from the public you know how you
know Congress person not only have a
little pin here but they never carry
anything it's always an assistant who's
carrying something and all they get is
people who are fawning over them and you
know so they're in their bubble and they
don't recognize I think that the country
is so cynical about them the congressmen
are cynical too I literally ran into
representative John Conyers in a dark
hallway he's the longest serving member
he complains that they are being deluged
by lobbyists are you seeing a lot of
Wall Street people donating to Congress
trying to stop the reforms I don't you
don't see that but you know it's going
on they haven't stopped
I mean the Congress wanted to reform
Financial you know the financial laws
and it seems like they're being stopped
at the regulatory level by all these
donations from members of Congress I
mean from Big Banks and and Wall Street
well it'll show up it shows up on the
quarterly said but I I have no reason to
believe that there's been any cessation
of reduction and so you get the same
results stagnation JPMorgan Chase has
shocked the markets by revealing a
trading loss of over two billion dollars
two weeks later it was reported that the
huge Bank JP Morgan Chase lost 2 billion
dollars gambling on exotic derivative
products and what they called a
synthetic credit portfolio if Jamie
Diamond makes this mistake
of America thanks to The Mistakes by JP
Morgan which is the biggest U.S Bank in
terms of assets rippled through the
financial world for many it brings back
memories of 2008 when big Banks risky
bets threatened to collapse the
financial system it was later reported
that the bank's lobbyists had fought
against the new rule that if passed
would have prevented this giant loss the
internet buzzed with the bad news
because this is the derivatives Market
this is very important could pan out to
be nothing
largest U.S Bank you know best buddies
with the FED
um and of course this is a whole lot of
debt but none of the commentary I saw
discussed the lobbying by JP Morgan
Chase you see Banks time and time again
getting into problems slipping up and
you've got America's biggest bank JP
Morgan doing exactly that and frankly
um the banks are Their Own Worst Enemy
we know we were sloppy we know we were
stupid we know there was bad judgment we
don't know if any of that's true yet of
course Regulators should look at
something like this that's their job so
you know we are totally open component
regulators and they will come through on
conclusions but we intend to fix it
learn from it and be a better company
when it's done one of the amazing
lessons I think of everything that led
up to the crash is they can't control
themselves even to the extent that they
will destroy their own industry even at
the extent they will destroy their own
companies the short-term profit motive
seeps in in so many pores of individuals
and divisions and offices and then whole
companies they will destroy themselves
so we definitely can't trust them to
figure out how to control themselves
public citizen later played a role
outlawing insider trading by members of
Congress on information they obtained in
hearings and investigations public
citizen considered it corruption
the notion that the powerful shouldn't
get to create one set of rules for
themselves and another set of rules for
everybody else
and if we expect that to apply to our
biggest corporations and to our most
successful citizens it certainly should
apply to our elected officials
especially at a time when there's a
deficit of trust between this city and
the rest of the country
thank you
Congressman Jesse Jackson Jr the son of
the famous Civil Rights leader has been
representing Chicago's second district
for 17 years he's consumed with
investigating and explaining how the
system was set up historically to serve
states rights and special interests
I filed an amendment to the Constitution
to guarantee us the right to a public
education of equal high quality why
because every American that's in a
public school
ought not be in states rights slavery in
other words the lesson of the
African-American overcoming the
Constitution with respect to states
rights was not heeded Through Time by
the American people and it is the exact
same system that they are stuck in today
and they just don't know it we asked him
why Congress has become so dysfunctional
I've never seen it more polarized I've
never seen it more divided along
geographical lines along factional lines
along
economic political lines
it's not what the democracy was
conceived to be it's not what it has he
it was supposed to evolve into
and unfortunately the American people
are are the victims of this process how
would you answer that question who rules
America there are two types of material
power in this country and in the world
one is political
and one is economic we the people have
the power politically to control and
determine the economic system and there
is a constant struggle between people
power and economic power
We the People control through the
political system are economic Destiny
and the economic Destiny of the nation
increasingly the heavy hand of the
economic system is controlling the
political system and manipulating the
people
who controls America
an elite group of people who function in
a stratosphere
globally and Beyond the Constitution
beyond the reach of government they have
enormous resources they own the media
the Power to investigate
uh they get to shape The Narrative of
the stories
they get to model and position
candidates for public office and shape
an image in front of the American people
an image that oftentimes does not jive
with reality and yet the American people
see this image of leadership and they
vote for it only to find out the human
frailties and the shortcomings of the
individual at a later date we met a
former Congressional staffer who worked
on the hill for a leading legislator for
12 years he agreed to talk with us only
if we blacked out his face and distorted
his voice he was scathing in his
description of how decisions get made
this is a great institution but
unfortunately you have
an Untold amount of members of Congress
that spend
60 percent of their time raising money
and then when because they got a run
every two years which makes no sense
um they have to raise millions of
dollars just to be competitive to go on
television
because the CBS ABC and NBC and CNN
charge this outrageous amount of money
to get TV commercials it ought to be
free or very low cost so what happens is
these members of Congress are relying on
well-intentioned
staffers many of them are just out of
college many of them were interns to
make major decisions on foreign policy
and domestic policy and health care and
employment and jobs and they're not
really mature enough he also told us
many of the staffers get bought off by
special interests and big donors and a
lot of these um young people are just
out of college instead of graduate
school they have to pay back these
enormous college loans and graduate
school loans they're paying unbelievable
rent in Washington DC any more than
Virginia oftentimes more than a third of
their income a lot of them were taken
care of out of work family members so
there's a pressure for them
I'm sorry on them to go work for the
money to interest on K Street a lot of
staffers even Progressive staffers
have left the hill and worked for the
large drug companies
work for the oil companies
well it's usually the biggest industry
it's usually the biggest companies in
whatever industry you're looking at if
you're looking at overall National
Economic Policy Wall Street is the
dominant influence you don't know what's
happening in the pharmaceutical industry
and you know there the big farm has got
cause the shots
um as as you know within the financial
industry which factions are most
important it's still really the biggest
institutions that set the agenda have
there been polls on where Americans
think our money goes in our government
and just about nobody has a clue people
wildly overestimate how much goes to Aid
and of course part of that is because we
talk about weaponizing foreign Nations
as Aid uh and and they're they wildly
underestimate how much goes to the
military
and yet says our whistle-blowing former
Congressional Aid the real problem is
not just corporate power
the
biggest problem in America is not the
corporations
it's not even necessarily the money for
campaigns the the biggest problem is
that the American people
don't really organize themselves in
their congressional districts to
mitigate the power of special interest
they're not utilizing their democracy
because they don't know how the game
works the donors know exactly how the
game works you give a member of Congress
the money they're gonna probably do what
they've asked them to do
so if you've got millions and millions
of people who voted for Obama or vote
for their member of Commerce and then
that's the end of their political
involvement well that's the end of
democracy
no serious about who rules America can
leave out wall Street's Financial clout
we've left its impact for last secure in
the knowledge that in today's America
this financial district is a key Power
Center a hub for the financialization of
an economy in which the control of big
money is often Central to the control of
politics and Society
we have spoken with a respected
corporate executive who told us Point
Blank that the rich now rule America
my personal opinion is a large part of
what's Happening economically is due to
basically globalization and digitization
of business that can't be stopped
Professor Stanley iranowitz quotes the
famous sociologist C Wright Mills on the
same theme from 50 years ago
grocery the financial sector is the
Leading Edge of corporate capital and it
was a Leading Edge of corporate capital
in the mid 50s of course today it's much
more accentuated because of the relative
decline of industrial corporations
I've heard things that'll blow your mind
and now I think it's time you get the
whole story
many Americans see all this as a
conspiracy by an unaccountable secret
cabal that operates like a power center
Beyond Democratic control the internet
is filled with videos about shadowy
billionaires and their plots that
control everything which is ongoing
right now it is a conspiracy of
institutional corruption from the
highest level from International Bankers
to the super rich from Washington to
Rome they're all in it together is Wall
Street a conspiracy and what role does
it play and who rules America is it an
outside job or an inside job
it's not a matter of
Elites outside the state although of
course they have enormous influence but
the reason they have enormous influence
because it's because the state is
structured to be reproducing their power
and authority in society Trio Panic he's
a economist and analyst and I think he
offered a perspective that we really
haven't heard before he's sort of
fighting against the conspiratorial idea
you know that there's a small group of
people in a room somewhere running
things he's talking about the structure
of the society the values of it who
really runs things
Wall Street is not only a place it's an
industry with thousands of
interconnected firms that call
themselves a financial services industry
but they are much more than that they
are deeply involved with how our country
is run says Robert Weissman the head of
the public interest group public citizen
well you can't understand what's
happening in the country in the last 30
years in terms of Economic Policy really
the way the country's evolved
politically without understanding how
Wall Street has grown in power it's
grown in economic power and it's grown
in political power and that's been
synergistic they use their political
power to wipe out a whole range of
regulations that control them in the
past investors would buy stocks in real
companies and industries that generated
jobs provided services or created
products of value those days are gone
they became a bigger and bigger portion
of the economy
then we went from an economy of
production making things to one based on
consumption buying and selling things
consumers soon drove 70 percent of the
economy as Banks private Equity
companies and hedge funds grew in size
as it became a bigger portion of the
economy they were able to leverage more
and more political power in a really
horrible cycle for the functioning of
democracy and what that led us up to of
course was the crash in 2008. so
consumers went deeper and deeper into
debt and then Bankers bought and sold
debt while they changed the rules
regulating their activities a whole
series of deregulatory moves that have
been enabled by the influence the
political influence of Wall Street led
to the actual functioning the economy to
be a disaster
because as billionaire investor George
Soros told me years ago the capitalist
economy is also inherently unstable and
prone to Bubbles and crashes I I've
worked with the theory that financial
markets are inherently unstable and to
prevent excesses you need some kind of
intervention supervision regulation
uh unfortunately the prevailing
idea is that markets tend towards
equilibrium and so we work with a false
concept of how financial markets operate
we were told by someone for example that
the beauty of globalization is that no
one is in control
well it there is a great advantage in
that because controls have their own
problems uh in fact markets are much
more efficient than centralized controls
but it doesn't mean that that there
should be absolutely no control and in
fact if you look at reality
ever since you've had capitalism and
ever since you have had financial
markets you have had a crises and each
time there was a crisis there was
something done to prevent a recurrence
the problem this time is the dramatic
surge in debt look at this these are
charts showing the debt of the United
States page after page illustrating how
much money is owed it's mind-boggling
it gets even more complicated when you
start talking about new financial
instruments like derivatives that have
turned the industry into a global Casino
derivatives can also be used as
insurance betting that a loan will or
won't default before a given date they
become the basis of a big betting system
like in a casino
Financial journalist Max Kaiser says
just a handful of big Financial firms
now dominate the industry and the global
economy without a doubt there's JP
Morgan which is in bed with the FED into
the central banking system
Wall Street bets on future values and
the performance of practically
everything of value
something about Morgan Goldman Sachs are
the two primary players in this in this
Global financialized world
soon CEOs financiers and Executives of a
small number of investment Banks and
hedge funds became rich and Powerful by
controlling specialized high-stakes
markets
they are connected to the central
banking system which is the fed the ECB
the bank of international settlements of
Switzerland is kind of the potential
Bank of the central banks and the these
are the folks that are keeping their
main purpose at this point is to keep
interest rates as close to zero as
possible to make it as cheap as possible
for people who are borrowing money to
speculate to be able to speculate freely
without having to pay for the money that
they're borrowing to speculate even if
these financial markets are supposedly
open to all a relatively few Traders
investors and asset managers came to
structure the markets to increase their
own wealth and power
and if they ever make a Bad Bet then
they quickly move to cover their bad
Bets with austerity programs or some
kind of bailout program or a
quantitative easing program
study by physicists on the ownership and
control of stock exchanges in 48
countries examined 24
877 stocks and a hundred and six
thousand one hundred and forty one
shareholding entities to their amazement
they found that just 10 companies were
dominating all stock ownership here they
are
when we talk about money and we talk
about Wall Street we have to ask this
question where does the money come from
that's used in the speculation in our
financial markets this man knows Barry
James Dyke he's an asset manager and he
works with clients so where does it come
from the money comes from people's
savings
regular old savings where people's
retirement funds which is saving for
retirement but to the people who put
their money into these accounts and know
how it's being invested or spent they
don't have a clue
it's only now as a result of the
financial crisis that the public is
learning slowly that the self-styled
Masters of the Universe on Wall Street
speculated on risky Investments and
created a crash
green Carter the editor of Vanity Fair
wrote it can fairly be said that the
chain of catastrophic bets made over the
past decade by a few hundred Bankers May
well turn out to be the greatest
non-violent crime against humanity in
history they brought the world's economy
to its knees lost tens of millions of
people their jobs in their homes and
crashed the retirement plans of a
generation and they could drive an
estimated 200 million people worldwide
into dire poverty
in 2010 before Occupy Wall Street labor
unions were marching to protest Wall
Street crimes
[Applause]
on the 29th of April this is a march on
Wall Street organized by the AFL-CIO
which says they've organized 200
protests so far but you never know it in
terms of the media coverage well today
the media is out and they're marching
because of a theft millions of jobs are
missing 11 million jobs according to the
AFL CIO they want payback they want Wall
Street to pay they want a new attack on
financial transaction
[Music]
[Applause]
we are trying to recover from a
financial crisis that some people say is
even worse than the depression in the
1930s and yet reforms that have been
proposed very modest reforms are being
fought tooth and nail at the regulatory
level by Wall Street firms and
financiers uh do you think that they
have a disproportionate power to
influence Congress there's no doubt
about that
not just the Congress but State
legislatures as well their strength
their power runs the entire Gambit of
the of the American political system
I read that the financial services
industry had hired 28 lobbyists per
member of Congress to try to influence
their decisions to try to inform how
what happens to you when lobbyists come
into your office to try to get you to
vote their way how does that work that
game well it's very hard to to get a
meeting with me I don't think that they
spent a lot of money trying to Lobby me
I'm kind of clear on my ideology clear
my view of representative government and
very clear on on the Constitution but
suffice it to say while my district is
competitive there are many more
competitive districts than mine and
every member of Congress to that extent
becomes a prisoner to the election
process to the fundraising process
Sheila krumholz of the center for
responsive politics says wall Street's
power is well documented
Wall Street the banks and the financial
industry writ large is the single
largest source of campaign cash in the
United States and it has been for years
if not decades
it is uh kind of following the Willy
Sutton rule of politics you go where the
money is that's where the money is they
have not just political action
committees that can Pony up uh maximum
amounts to influential members of
Congress who have jurisdiction over
their industry but also they can Pony up
pass the hat and pony up hundreds of
thousands of dollars just among their
partners and vice presidents and
Executives in their companies she says
their clout will impact the election in
2012.
so they can muster a ton of money and
this is also seen specifically in the
presidential race in 2012 where of
course Mitt Romney has hailed from the
private into private Equity industry and
prior to that Barack Obama had been
darling of Wall Street so Wall Street
and and banks in particular are an
enormously influential part of the U.S
industry
that power is being shown as Wall Street
lobbyists try to sabotage Financial
reforms passed by Congress
two years after the passage of the
legislation and are The Regulators doing
the good things that Congress told them
to do and the answer to a considerable
extent is no they're way behind on
issuing the rules are supposed to issue
where they actually have issued the
rules are getting challenged in almost
every instance in court by the Chamber
of Commerce or the financial securities
Roundtable or other Wall Street interest
and they're having a tough time with the
Judiciary that's favorable to big
business and maintaining the rules that
they've issued so reforms can be passed
but they can also be sabotaged
right they get multiple bites at the
Apple they get abide in Congress where
they've got enormous power but at least
it's mostly a public fight and then they
go to the Regulatory Agencies where they
also have enormous power but it's
usually below the radar off the front
pages and they don't even have the
public school day
recently on a radio show I host I
discussed Wall Street power in the
financial meltdown with financial
journalist Max Kaiser and Stacy Herbert
as well as Andy stephanian an animal
rights activist who led a campaign
against the company in the business of
painful medical tests on poppies after
his group drove their stock price down
the company went broke but then the
government labeled him a financial
terrorist and sent him to prison
we began by comparing Wall Street to the
Titanic the unsinkable ship that sank
if the Titanic were the story today the
difference would be that Goldman Sachs
and JP Morgan would have heavy bets that
would pay off when the ship sinks and
Hank Paulson would be down there
widening the gash it brings me to a new
study out just recently and they looked
at hundreds of shipwrecks throughout the
hundreds past few hundred years and what
they found is that the norm is actually
for women and children to die more
frequently than men and that the captain
usually didn't go down with the ship
they were usually the the their survival
rate was the highest these guys they
they use derivatives as Warren Buffett
calls them Weapons of Mass Financial
destruction to to make situations worse
because they're bets that they have uh
on on these calamities becoming worse
pay off enormously and we see that in
the in the numbers in the bonuses it's
reflected and you nodding before when
Max was speaking about all of this is
this really true that they're betting
against you know us in a sense betting
against uh you know hoping for bad
things to happen I don't think that
everybody that works on Wall Street has
this mentality but there is a culture
that's in place where people have
learned to at least accept and and
justify Behavior like looking at these
Investments betting Investments against
you know things to fail whether it be a
government whether it be a country or
whether it be a company to fail and and
say oh well I can justify this and you
look at it like it's numbers you don't
look at the people behind it you don't
look at the families that suffer you
don't look at the country that suffers
as a result well here's what what you
know is is mind-boggling to me is you
are presenting a picture of
intentionality that people did things to
further their own interests they knew
what they were doing it was calculated
and yet in most of the media
uh it seems as if it's presented as some
sort of mistake as miscalculation a g we
wanted housing to go up but it went down
you can't blame us everybody was doing
it there therefore nobody was doing it
therefore nobody can be prosecuted well
it's assuming that there was intention
uh is that a good thing or a bad thing
some would argue that it's it's a good
thing to have people who are who are
parasites in an economy because
parasites are useful I have parasites
and my intestines they perform a useful
function the problem is the parasites
don't run my hard lungs and brain in in
America the parasites write the
regulatory framework that's supposed to
be governing them so the parasites run
the show is Wall Street affecting you
know capitalist is Wall Street affecting
our policy making well they're becoming
our policy makers at least for a short
period of time and then returning back
to the banks and there's an evolving
door kind of thing essentially I mean
they're in and out of whether it be the
Bush Administration or the Obama
Administration the
different positions within the cabinet
that are you know governing Finance are
individuals that are former CEOs of
banks where they might go back to being
an honorary chair on the board of
directors it's it's this incestuous
relationship between Wall Street and
policy sounds so corrupt Danny you asked
who runs America and I say it's
ignorance and you know Thomas Jefferson
warned of this and that we needed a
media who would inform the population
otherwise we would lose our democracy so
this is ignorance that is being forced
upon criminalizing knowledge this is
something that I was startled by when
NASDAQ opened up you know on in Times
Square a big Studio out front with a big
window and you know and then I I said
I'd love to tour the exchange and uh you
know this was the time that Bernie
Madoff was running the NASDAQ you know
and they said you can't tour The
Exchange there is no exchange it looks
like in exchange there's a building that
says NASDAQ but the actual operations
are computers algorithmic trading goes
well beyond that as you're alluding to
it's not about individuals who are
taking any risks personally to make a
market as part of a capitalist system
these are computers that have virtually
unlimited credit because the cost of
credit is now zero and the ability for a
bank like JP Morgan with a 90 trillion
dollar balance sheet of derivatives they
can land a trillion dollars to leader
program to make a bet if the BET doesn't
work then they get a federal bailout if
the BET works then they get a bonus so
it says they win tells we lose and this
has been going on now for a number of
years but it's gotten shockingly more
disproportionate and asymmetric
this shift towards super fast computers
is just another example of the deeper
shift we've seen in power as Finance in
effect takes over with politicians
courting Wall Street at Global
conferences and in private meetings as
George Soros explains
it is actually symptomatic of the age
because you have
presidents and prime ministers courting
the the the
financiers and the industrialists
so it does show a shift in in the
relative power but I I don't want to
convey
see I don't believe that that business
can in any way replace the power of the
state because it's different kind of
power so the the sovereignty is still in
the hands of the state Wall Street you
know it sounds like a conspiracy theory
but Wall Street controls everything you
know I mean they're the major
shareholders of all the major companies
look at the BP oil spill who is who is
the owner of BP oil spill the biggest
shareholders JP Morgan
there's so much happening now you know
there's no stopping what's happening now
the system everyone knows the system's
broken whether you're a you know a one
percenter or 99 or a republican a
Democrat Anarchist communist capitalist
everyone knows the system is broken so
now we need to fix it
we'll give the last word to a scholar
with a longer view American historian
Eric foner I think what we face is a
serious democracy deficit not only in
the United States but in many other
countries as well I'm not quite ready to
say a plutocracy determines everything
that happens in the United States but I
think the Democracy deficit arises from
the fact that
fundamental issues are now just off
limits from democracy it doesn't matter
who is elected the basic issues about
Finance about de-industrialization uh
things like that are about globalization
about the loss of power of ordinary
people over their own lives
that's not open to discussion I don't
care if it's Democrat Republican Obama
Romney
that's not part of what their debate is
you their debate is at the margins so
that the fundamental issues facing
Ordinary People are not subject to
democratic consideration government does
not represent the ordinary people even
though people elect the government the
government does not respond at all to
the needs and aspirations of Ordinary
People
in this series we've investigated who
rules America examining the history of
deep conflicts in this country going
back to the American Revolution we've
dissected the power of the military
corporations the media and Wall Street
we have shown that these powerful forces
often undermine democracy rather than
strengthen it
there is a battle on the way for the
soul of America for whom rules America
that has put these deeper issues on the
agenda the question is a fundamental
transformation possible or will special
interests in the wealthiest Americans
continue to dominate in a country that
says it's the most dynamic democracy on
Earth
the belief in our democracy is almost an
article of religious Faith even though
there's a separation of church and state
perhaps that's why the views you've
heard in this series are rejected by The
Establishment rejected by Academia
rejected by the Press they believe only
the people have power if anyone does but
opinion leaders don't look into it they
don't focus on interest they focus on
ideologies on personalities not
institutions the idea of a power elite
is an anathema to them because if people
believed it that might spur
dissatisfaction and dissent
the age of the internet and global
television you can't stop people from
being exposed to counter narratives to
official myths these issues are
debatable of course but most political
coverage doesn't debate other ways of
looking at the world it relies on the
usual pundits recycling conventional
wisdom
they don't ask who rules America
members of Congress I have the high
privilege and the distinct honor of
presenting to you the president of the
United States
[Applause]
[Music]